my prince man latin EMA's you've been
here rehearsing how are you feeling
about it so far you got a couple
performances I'm feeling Greg got two
performances my first ones with maluma
our song in the cloud which hit number
one like three weeks on the line airplay
chart bearing inside is gonna be dub
it's it's it's a different vibe we got
the whole stage so I'm really excited
about that lots of pyro yeah lots of
dancers and I'm also performing with
people and Ludacris a brand new song
that actually comes out the night of the
AMA and it's a slow jam it's actually um
kind of a flip of well it's it's an oh
well it was us remember us your song
lovers and friends which actually theirs
was a flip of an oven of a old-school
R&B yeah so we kind of bring that back
and that's a really cool sensual
romantic song so I'm excited to get
together with pit and loot as well oh so
this is some baby-making music you're
doing you know I'm saying I would
comment winter's coming so it's like
that you know that that baby-making see
this coming and the night of the a mains
we also got a we got I got a record with
a CNC oh they're also which they're also
performing right I'm at the line a maze
so it comes out the night of the AMA so
I'm excited it's gonna be loud to
celebrate I'm ready to chill have fun
with the fans and just cheer what have
fun with a lot of celebration I'm sure a
lot of partying to I mean you guys are
all homies in this community always oh
yeah it's always great when you come to
these award show you catch up a lot of
the homies a lot of my friends you know
pity me and him you know I don't see him
as often when you get together in these
award shows it's just one big party and
you you we have fun with it we really do
yeah so you rot you're about to break
the internet with maluma - you guys are
both gonna be on that stage who's taking
the shirt off first we're gonna take the
shirt off at the same no I'm asking for
them we're gonna see we're gonna um you
know they don't plan it and hit us up we
didn't we we got a we out we got to feel
the vibe we're to feel the moment all
right what if it happens we'll be at the
same summit the same exact time so it
tells me is kind of happy you guys got
to put it out there even if you're
watching it's got a right towards our
tweeters Instagram us and stay tuned
there's gonna be a lot of fun tell me
what you want all right
the for the first time ever there's all
female hosts that's this thing I mean I
know Latin music did you know that yeah
five or six of them you know I mean I'm
cool with that
right right
listen the Latin music sometimes can be
so male-dominated what's it like to see
women latin women finally get there do I
think it's awesome you know I get along
well with Carol G Becky G we got a
record coming out later this month
got collab wit with JLo live collab with
Dahlia with Shakira and I think to see
you know all these women that
represented our culture and then also
the upcoming females and actresses and
singer/songwriter that are doing their
thing I think it's great I think it's
great I think it's good time we know
we've been waiting for that time and I'm
so proud to see that there's kind of
like this movement of women I'm taking
over all the Latin charts
they're kicking my ass it's all good you
know there's room for everybody right
and the plots are easy on the eyes I was
even on Becky G and I think I thought I
was a song scene for yam I did a little
cameo on it Beto's about to hit a
billion so I'm all for supporting women
and you know my fan base I had a lot of
girls to support my music so um power to
the to the female for sure dude you've
been climbing I mean just the ranks
every year getting bigger and bigger was
this past your particular meant to you
it's been a great year I'm excited I got
a lot of music coming out in the next
month like four songs different rhythms
different genres I think this year for
me has been experimenting with with with
different rhythms also collaborating a
lot of artists I think in the last two
three years we're seeing so much talent
and Latin music and you know we see so
many people getting success and that
makes me really proud you know I've been
in the game for a while now and I think
it feels good to see all this young new
talent gonna come on absolutely who you
gonna work with there's anyone you're
still like oh man I would love to clap I
love to collab with Mark Anthony I think
he's somebody that I've always looked up
to he's done a really great job he's
from New York I love to collab with
cardi big as well so there's a lot
there's so many artists man and you know
sometimes these collaborations you don't
really plan them sometimes you get a
song that says man this song reminds me
of this person I wonder if the vibe with
it so I think it's all you know a lot of
the songs that I got that I've done has
been you know friendships and collabs
that happen pretty much organic you can
happen here at the AMAs just over a
train or you go out for a bar you know
you end up in the studio happens all the
time acts right I think a lot of our
collaborations and songs actually happen
after war so
I can't see what's gonna cook up after
this one happen either you get a
collaboration you get hungover the other
way was a fun time right other ways a
fun so now you're a fun time bro yeah
[Music]